[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi, and
welcome to episode
number 143 of the weekly
Google Cloud Platform Podcast.
I'm Mark Mandel and I'm here
with my colleague, Melanie
Warrick.
Hey, Melanie.
MELANIE WARRICK: Hi Mark.
MARK MANDEL: How are you doing?
MELANIE WARRICK: I'm OK.
How are you?
MARK MANDEL: Good.
MELANIE WARRICK: We're
not doing Next anymore.
MARK MANDEL: We're not.
MELANIE WARRICK: At
least for eight months.
MARK MANDEL: At least for
eight months, exactly.
So this week we have
Steren and Stewart
from the App Engine team
joining us to talk all
about what's new in App Engine.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah,
I should clarify.
We are still sharing
interviews that we
captured while we were at Next.
MARK MANDEL: That's true.
MELANIE WARRICK: We're
just not at Next anymore.
Anyways, yes.
That will be a good episode.
We know one of our
listeners actually
has been asking for
when this is coming.
So--
MARK MANDEL: Here it is.
MELANIE WARRICK: This
will be the episode.
As always, we have our
cool things of the week
and we're going to end with
the question of the week, which
is a question we
came up with when
we were looking at our
cool things of the week,
actually, which is
what does it mean
when there's a
recommendation that you
should update your image.
MARK MANDEL: What does it mean?
MELANIE WARRICK: So we'll
find out what that means.
Maybe that just means change
the picture you're using.
MARK MANDEL: Change the
background wallpaper
on your computer.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Maybe change the cat.
[CAT MEOWING] So cool
things of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: Mark, I
know you found this first one
and you were so disappointed
that I didn't know about it.
MARK MANDEL: So there's an
article about the robot dance
party that we created at Next.
OK, so unfortunately,
it's not real robots.
SPEAKER: (ROBOT VOICE) Whatever.
MELANIE WARRICK: When
you first told me
that, I was looking at it going,
wait, this is going to have,
like, actual robots
dancing around.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, no, so
it was actually really cool.
SPEAKER: (ROBOT VOICE)
That is correct.
MARK MANDEL: If you happened
to check out the media
and entertainment section
if you were at Next,
there was a bunch
of animators who
were there creating an animated
short of dancing robots.
And--
MELANIE WARRICK: And they were
working with somebody remotely,
too, out of L.A.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, exactly.
So they had a third
person who was in L.A.
and they were doing it
all at the same time.
They're all working
together with remote work
and the people who were
there and all doing
all the collaboration.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah, they
were using virtual workstations
to be able to collaborate using
some of the Google Cloud tools
with other tools, as well,
to basically animate, create
these animated robots
to do the dance.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: And with
a little D.J. as well.
SPEAKER: (ROBOT VOICE) It's
time to rock this place, yo.
MELANIE WARRICK: The
video of what they created
is actually on the site.
They spent three days
on the show floor
and remotely, coordinating
and animating and using
things like Firestore
and rendered workers.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
MELANIE WARRICK:
You know, I know
rendering actual images,
like animated images,
takes a significant
amount of time.
And what's kind of cool
is they were actually
able to assign multiple
workers to render each frame.
And we're talking, I
think it was 1,500 frames
is what they listed?
MARK MANDEL: That's pretty cool.
MELANIE WARRICK: Or
something around that.
So they could just
do it all in parallel
because it takes 13 to 30
minutes per frame to render.
MARK MANDEL: Got it.
My favorite part is the two
dancers were Fred and Ginger.
Now, they had a four armed
robot called DJ Half-K
because it was four arms.
Kubernetes has eight,
so it's a Half-K.
MELANIE WARRICK: Ba dum bum.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: I liked it.
MELANIE WARRICK: So
anyway, robot dance party.
We'll put the link
in the show notes.
Another thing that
we wanted to mention
for cool things of the week is
what's happening in BigQuery.
We had some stuff
that was announced,
and it's official that BigQuery
Machine Learning is in beta.
So this is BigQuery's
way of providing tools
to do feature engineering,
modeling, in BigQuery
so you don't have to do any
moving of the data, which
is pretty great.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, that's cool.
MELANIE WARRICK: It's supposed
to work natively in SQL.
This is really helpful for those
who are working with databases
and working with SQL.
They also have the BigQuery
GIS, which is in public alpha.
And this is their Geospatial
Information System
integrated with BigQuery.
So it's allowing
you to basically use
data to support geospatial
data types and functions.
It also has a viz tool
that's on top of it
to help you actually apply
this to maps directly.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
MELANIE WARRICK: You
should check it out.
A couple other
announcements in here
like clustering and
data transfer services,
so you can take a look and see
what's going on with BigQuery.
MARK MANDEL: BigQuery just keeps
getting awesomer and awesomer.
MELANIE WARRICK: I know.
This whole idea of
trying to couple tools
where the data lives
is a smart move.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
I like it.
I like it a lot.
Finally, the nice
security thing.
So as you may have
heard earlier this year,
Project Zero at Google
disclosed some security flaws
in speculative
execution, particularly
Spectre and Meltdown.
As of-- I'm looking
at the 14th of August,
Intel published details on a
new set of speculative execution
vulnerabilities
called L1TR for short.
The TLDR-- and I'm
not a security expert,
so I'll read this here-- is that
Google Compute Engine employs
host isolation features which
ensures that an individual core
is never concurrently shared.
MELANIE WARRICK: So one
thing to note about L1TF
is that what's a little
different from Spectre
is that this variant exploits
speculative execution
by attacking the configuration
of processor-level data
structures rather than the
program's control flow.
So that's where
this is different.
And that's where
it's referring to L1.
It has to do
specifically with L1
cache and how
that's being handled
and ways in which
that can be accessed.
And so Google is
taking certain steps,
has mitigations against L1TF.
And I know, Mark, you were
going to mention some of those.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so they've
already deployed mitigations
to Google's infrastructure,
including the infrastructure
that underpins Google Cloud,
which basically prevents
the creation of the
vulnerable page table
entries within the host OS.
So TLDR, you should be fine.
Everything should be fine.
We are advocating--
MELANIE WARRICK: No.
Everything is on fire.
[EMERGENCY SIRENS]
MARK MANDEL:
Everything is on fire.
Well, everything is on fire
but you should be fine.
We are advocating, as per usual,
like, good standard stuff.
Make sure your images
are up to date.
Make sure all your
software is up to date.
SPEAKER: (ROBOT VOICE)
What does that mean?
MELANIE WARRICK: And for
those who are saying, well,
what does that mean?
Well, we're going to talk
about that after the interview.
MARK MANDEL: We are.
MELANIE WARRICK: And now I think
it's time for us to go talk
with Steren and Stewart.
MARK MANDEL: Let's get to it.
MELANIE WARRICK: All right.
MARK MANDEL: Well, I'm
very excited to have yet
another interview here
on the Next show floor.
We have Steren Giannini
and Stewart Reichling,
both product managers
at Google Cloud.
How are you both doing?
STEWART REICHLING: Doing
great, how are you?
STEREN GIANNINI: Pretty good.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
You're here to tell us all
about App Engine and all
the amazing new things that
are happening with App Engine.
Before we do that, do
you want to tell us
a little bit about
both of yourselves
and what you do here at Google.
STEREN GIANNINI: Sounds good.
I'm a product manager on Google
Cloud in the serverless team.
Personally, I'm a
NodeJS developer,
so that's why I handled
some NodeJS things regarding
App Engine.
STEWART REICHLING: Cool.
I am also a product
manager on App Engine.
Steren and I sit
on the same team
and I'm more of a Python guy.
MELANIE WARRICK: Wow,
that was a good one.
So what's going on
with App Engine?
STEWART REICHLING:
So we, if you've
listened to any of
the announcements
over the last couple
of days, we have
a lot of exciting, new things
to announce for App Engine.
We're making a big
push on App Engine.
App Engine has always been
about a really strong developer
experience or security built
in the serverless model,
and we're here to
talk about that today.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so people
who aren't familiar with App
Engine, give us the pitch.
STEREN GIANNINI: All right.
App Engine is a fully managed
serverless application
platform.
It was really serverless
before it was cool.
So it scales to zero,
you pay for what you use,
and there is no
server management.
We entirely abstract the
infrastructure from you.
Deployments are source-based.
So what you give is your
application source code.
Then it deploys fast.
There's a built pipeline.
There's a built-in versioning
and traffic-splitting features.
STEWART REICHLING: Yeah.
So it's often just
been about, you
are a developer who
wants to write your code.
You don't want to have
to think about setting up
and wiring and the complicated
things around scaling.
App Engine's really supposed to
give you that simple developer
experience, plus things like
a pay-per-use billing model
and good scaling.
MELANIE WARRICK: And we
use App Engine for our--
MARK MANDEL: Podcast.
MELANIE WARRICK: --website.
MARK MANDEL: Yes, we do.
MELANIE WARRICK:
For the podcast.
STEWART REICHLING: Nice.
A lot of people do.
MARK MANDEL: But serverless
is, like, totally 2018.
Hasn't App Engine been
around longer than that?
STEWART REICHLING: Sure, yeah.
App Engine's been around
since, what, 2008?
We celebrated our 10
year anniversary recently
STEREN GIANNINI: Yeah, we did.
10 years.
STEWART REICHLING: If
listened to Oren Teich's talk
two days ago, he called it
the OG serverless product.
And I think that's
exactly right.
Its serverless before serverless
was this cool, trendy buzzword.
STEREN GIANNINI:
So we can even say
that App Engine was here
before Google Cloud was
a thing, right?
App Engine was the platform
before Google Cloud platform
even existed.
MELANIE WARRICK:
It started it all.
STEREN GIANNINI: Yeah,
and initially, it
had all of those features
built into App Engine.
So Datastore is actually
originally an App Engine
feature.
And now they are full,
stand alone Cloud products.
MELANIE WARRICK: So what's
new with App Engine?
STEREN GIANNINI: The world
has changed in 10 years,
and a lot of web
frameworks have appeared.
And originally, App
Engine was a little bit
forcing you to use a
certain programming model.
And all of that has changed now.
App Engine is now
what we say idiomatic.
So in Cloud Next we
introduced what we called
the second generation runtimes.
And those generation
runtimes really
allow you to use an idiomatic
developer experience.
STEWART REICHLING: So the idea
is, I'm a Python developer,
I want to be able to write
Python code, not necessarily
App Engine code.
Steren is a Node developer.
Steren wants to write
Node code, not necessarily
App Engine code.
And so as part of that, we
have these new runtimes,
three of them right
now to announce.
We have Node 8,
that was actually
previewed at Google I/O.
We have Python 3.7 coming
in the next week or so, PHP 7.2.
I'm actually not
sure when this airs.
It might be out by the
time this comes out.
And then we're working on
some other languages, as well.
And the idea behind all of
these, the unifying theme,
is that they are
idiomatic, which
means that you write the
language that you know.
You don't think about
using proprietary stuff.
MARK MANDEL: And that actually
is probably a good question,
as well.
So it's idiomatic.
What am I writing
this stuff for?
Is it, like, websites?
Like, what am I doing
with this stuff?
STEWART REICHLING:
For sure, yeah.
We see all kinds of
different use cases.
A lot of them are web
apps, microservices,
anything that needs scale,
either scaling up very fast,
so you get a ton of traffic.
App Engine scales automatically
for you to meet that need.
Or you're not using
it very frequently.
It scales down to zero.
And so in that case, you're
not paying for anything.
During Oren's talk, there was--
"The New York Times,"
actually, is a great example
where they have these crosswords
that are super popular.
Right when they
come out, everybody
rushes online to
try and solve them.
Well, how do you provision
infrastructure for that?
You either don't provision
enough, in which case
you're losing customers,
or you way overprovision,
in which case you're
paying for stuff
that's not even getting used.
And so App Engine is
the perfect use case
for something like that.
Suddenly you get
a lot of traffic.
It scales up.
STEREN GIANNINI: I'm always
amazed by the creativity
of our customers.
Like, so many people build
their entire businesses
on top of App Engine.
Many use cases are about
mobile backends or REST APIs,
or even internet
applications because you just
deploy your app and then you
don't have to worry about it.
It just runs.
So that abstracts away
the operations for you
to focus on your business value.
STEWART REICHLING:
And so you've also
been a big push on getting
headless Chrome and features
like that built in.
Why does that matter
for App Engine?
STEREN GIANNINI: Yeah.
So you can easily build
very small services
that are super dedicated
to doing one thing.
For example, we put
all of the OS packages
needed to run headless
Chrome on App Engine.
So if you want to run one
service that just takes
a screenshot of a web
page or generates a PDF,
you can do that on
App Engine and you
don't have to worry about it.
It just works.
STEWART REICHLING:
So it meets needs--
MARK MANDEL: That's cool.
STEWART REICHLING: --all the
way from big web apps down
to developer tools,
internal tools
that you're building yourself.
MELANIE WARRICK: What
are some examples
that you've seen
that you've been
pretty impressed by in terms
of how it's been applied?
STEREN GIANNINI: Well, we as--
we said-- we have some
amazing customers.
Like I think the most famous
one is probably Snapchat.
So that's pretty
amazing what they
built on top of
App Engine, going
from a very small company
to this massive scale using
our platform.
MARK MANDEL: One of my
favorites, episode 26-- no,
23--
with the-- if anyone
plays video games
like I do-- a Humble Bundle
that runs on top of App Engine.
STEWART REICHLING: OK.
Oh, wow.
MARK MANDEL: And they
actually specifically--
because they do an
event-- well, they
used to do especially
at an event-based model
where it was like, they have
these events for cheap games.
And so they get massive spikes.
And having App Engine, they
said it was really great.
STEWART REICHLING:
Yeah, Humble Bundle's
a great use case for that.
STEREN GIANNINI: Khan Academy,
we are very proud to host them.
STEWART REICHLING: "New
York Times," as I mentioned.
You can go on the website.
There's customers of all
sizes use App Engine,
have been using App
Engine for 10 years.
One of the things that
I hear from customers,
which is pretty cool, is you
often get people who say,
you know, the thing I
launched five years ago,
I can still go use that today.
It still exists today.
It still runs in
its current form.
They haven't been paying
for it that whole time.
But you see even small things
like my first experience
with App Engine was writing
a portfolio website.
STEREN GIANNINI: I probably
have my own website I deployed.
It was a game website
in 2011, I think.
It's still running today.
Just hit the URL and it's there.
MARK MANDEL: That's
pretty amazing.
So Steren, you said something
earlier, which I thought
was interesting,
when we were talking
about the history of
App Engine and how
Datastore was once integrated.
And I know now Datastore
has been pulled out
as a whole separate product.
Are there other products that
are upcoming that are maybe
being pulled out of
App Engine so that they
can be used in other contexts?
STEREN GIANNINI: Yeah, we are
graduating some App Engine
exclusive features into
cloud-wide products.
So Datastore is a
good example of that.
At Next yesterday we
announced that the task queue
feature of App Engine is now
a standalone Cloud product.
It's called Cloud Tasks.
So task queues are very
useful when you want
to do things asynchronously.
So for example, you have
to do some computation.
It can take some
time and you don't
want to delay the
response to your users.
You will create a
task in a queue.
Cloud Task will make
sure that this task
is executed at least once, and
most of the time exactly once.
STEWART REICHLING:
Cloud Scheduler,
another great example.
App Engine has long had this
built-in cron functionality.
And again, this
stuff, it originated
when these services and concepts
didn't really exist yet.
So there's a service that
you could use previously
to just say, hey, I want
this to run on this schedule.
Now we're exposing that as a
first party cloud services.
So you can make sure that any
arbitrary HTTP target gets
accessed on a certain schedule
by the minute, by the hour,
by the day, fully customizable.
And these are features that you
can now use with App Engine.
You can use them
with Compute Engine.
You can use them with anything.
MARK MANDEL: That's awesome.
I'm not saying I've just
created an App Engine
app just to fire cron tasks
off before, but maybe I have.
STEWART REICHLING:
Yeah, well, you
won't have to do
that in the future.
And we're going to have a bunch
more announcements like this
in the next couple
of months where
we're taking these
services and making
them available to everybody.
MELANIE WARRICK: Any that
you can share right now?
STEWART REICHLING: No comment.
MELANIE WARRICK:
That's a good answer.
MARK MANDEL: We had to try.
STEREN GIANNINI: We can
talk about the recent things
we launched on the App Engine
to show that we actually
are heavily investing
into the platform.
So earlier this
year, we completely
changed the autoscaling
algorithm of all of App Engine.
Nobody noticed it, but
it was a massive change
of our infrastructure.
And as a consequence,
most of our customers
got better performances
and lower cost.
So we reduced the
bills of our customers
without them having
to do anything.
STEWART REICHLING: It's
one of the benefits
of having a managed platform
is things like that,
things like security.
These are things that you
don't have to think about,
which normally you would
have people dedicated
to think about these
things and you'd
spend a lot of time trying to
figure out how you can optimize
your infrastructure.
Because you're on App
Engine, that stuff
is just kind of handled for you.
STEREN GIANNINI: And
another feature that I
personally like a lot is that--
so App Engine, you
deploy your app.
Good.
But you probably want to put
that app under your custom
domain.
And we provide a one-click
HTTPS for your custom domain.
MARK MANDEL: Security people
must love you for that.
STEREN GIANNINI: Yes.
MELANIE WARRICK: I was
going to say, yeah.
STEWART REICHLING: I was just
going to talk a little bit more
about what it means
to be idiomatic.
For us, one of the
longstanding pieces of feedback
that we've gotten
from customers is
that, as I mentioned
before, people look at it
and they go, oh, I have to
do these special things.
My app will only work in
this App Engine environment
if I design it for this.
I maybe already have a
workload that I want to move in
or I have something
that I want to move out
to see how it might do in
a different environment.
Because we're launching
these much more open source
experiences, that means that
you can use any library,
framework, dependency
that you want.
You don't have to use these
proprietary APIs anymore.
All of these things
should just work the way
you expect them to work.
STEREN GIANNINI: So
I'm a Node developer.
I can get anything
from any npm--
MARK MANDEL: Oh, wow.
STEREN GIANNINI: --even
the binary modules.
They just work on App Engine.
STEWART REICHLING: Same for
Python. requirements.txt,
put your dependencies in there.
When you deploy, it all
gets installed for you
with the correct versions
that you've requested.
We're even looking
into other standards
like PIP file because
we love Python.
We want to make sure this is the
best place to run your Python
applications.
STEREN GIANNINI:
And we also made
sure to put some very useful
OS packages in your base image,
which is, by the way, Ubuntu.
So you get a regular
Ubuntu filled
with some pretty useful
packages, like ImageMagick
or FFmpeg and everything
to run headless Chrome,
as we mentioned.
MARK MANDEL: You seem very, very
happy about headless Chrome.
STEREN GIANNINI: Yeah.
It's a nice use case, right?
Just run Chrome on your server.
MARK MANDEL: That's great.
So are you able to talk about
why this change happened?
Like, it seems
like there's like--
I think you used the term second
generation earlier, Steren?
STEWART REICHLING: Yeah,
I think a big part of it
is customer feedback.
We've heard from
customers for a long time
that having to think
about your application
in this specific model
is an impediment.
It's also part of the
reason why some customers
choose things like VMs
instead, because it gives them
that fully-baked
experience where they
can install whatever they want.
So lifting these
restrictions is really
based on customer feedback.
STEREN GIANNINI: And
to achieve that, we
leveraged a very big
investment that we've
made into our infrastructure.
So technically, those
second generation runtimes
are enabled by a
new technical stack.
It's all based on gvisor,
which is a container runtime
sandbox--
which is, by the
way, open source.
You can check it out on GitHub.
So all of those runtimes, new
runtimes, second generation
runtimes, are built using
that new sandbox, which
allows us to really follow
this idiomatic experience,
bringing any module you
want in that sandbox.
STEWART REICHLING:
And just rewinding,
when App Engine first came into
existence, a lot of this stuff
did not even exist.
And so now we have
this new sandbox.
Previously, you had to
do a whole lot of things
to the language itself in
order to make it run securely
on our data centers.
STEREN GIANNINI:
Yeah, we had to.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Just you, right?
Just you.
MARK MANDEL: It's just Steren.
I was going to say,
does that mean, then,
that I know some feedback
I've heard previously,
like, sometimes we
aren't necessarily as
fast as our users would
like, I would say,
in updating versions of
languages and stuff like that.
Is this going to mean
that we're going to get
those updates a lot faster?
STEREN GIANNINI: So exactly.
This new technical
stack will allow
us to first deliver new
languages to App Engine
standard environment.
So NodeJS is the first example
of a new language which
we introduced on the
standard environment,
and also will allow us to
first update for other existing
languages and keep updating
them as the releases comes in.
STEWART REICHLING: Yeah, and as
I've mentioned multiple times,
everything should just
work out of the box.
If it doesn't, you
know, get in touch.
Put our emails on the website.
We want to hear your feedback.
So if something doesn't work the
way you expect, please let us
know.
MARK MANDEL: So everything
should work out of the box?
STEWART REICHLING: It
should work out of the box.
MARK MANDEL: Out of the box.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Or they call you.
MARK MANDEL: We'll put
your email on there.
It'll be fine.
MELANIE WARRICK: And
your phone number.
STEREN GIANNINI: Please do.
Please do.
MELANIE WARRICK: So
in terms of working
with App Engine, what are
resources you would recommend?
STEWART REICHLING: Sure.
So I would foremost
recommend our docs pages.
That's where we
try to put all of
the Getting Started information
you need, everything like that.
Whereas previously we had
this very heavyweight doc
set that told you all about
the specific intricacies
that you needed to know
since these were slightly
different environments,
it's much lighter
now because most of the stuff
that you actually needed
to know, you can find anywhere.
It's just if I know how to write
Python, my Python should work.
If I know how to write
Node, my Node should work.
You don't really need
to learn and keep
as much in your head anymore.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great.
STEREN GIANNINI: So for example,
if you're a NodeJS developer,
you probably have
already an existing app.
Well, without any
modification, there
is a very high probability
that it will just work
if you deploy it to App Engine.
So that could be
a good start, too,
trying to port an
existing app and bring it
to App Engine with just one
command, gcloud app deploy,
deploys to the cloud.
STEWART REICHLING: Let
me also add to that,
there is a generous free tier.
You can just deploy your app,
try it out, see how it works.
If it doesn't work, no sweat.
If you want something
different, no sweat.
But we actually
think you're going
to like it and stick to it.
MARK MANDEL: So it's an
interesting question, I think--
I think it's an
interesting question.
That's why I'm asking it.
For those people who are
currently on App Engine
and have apps
running, is like, do
they need to change their
code or is it still fine?
Or what's the deal there?
STEWART REICHLING:
Before Node 8 there
were no existing
Node 8 customers.
MARK MANDEL: That's true.
STEWART REICHLING: So this
is mostly a Python question.
There's still the
Python 2.7 environment.
For Python, 3.7,
yes, if you're just
trying to migrate
your app, you're
going to have to make
some changes to it.
We think those changes
will make your workloads
more portable in the future,
better in the future,
and more future-proof.
But as I said, you know,
your existing stuff
will continue to run.
This new runtime is really
an incremental new feature
to which you can deploy
now idiomatic apps the way
you would expect in
any other environment.
MARK MANDEL: So
nothing's breaking.
It's just if you want to
keep pushing new stuff--
STEWART REICHLING:
That's exactly right.
MARK MANDEL: Beautiful.
So who's using this right now?
Are people using
the new runtime?
Have you got any people
who are trying this out?
STEREN GIANNINI: So we announced
the availability of NodeJS
on App Engine standard
environment at Google I/O
earlier this year.
So today we've seen some
pretty good adoption
from the Node community.
And the new runtimes are
just opening up right now.
STEWART REICHLING: Yeah, so
Python 3.7, PHP 7.2, those
are still in private
alpha right now.
We've got customers using them,
giving us feedback every day.
Expect those to go to beta very
soon, or maybe already in beta.
STEREN GIANNINI: And by the
way, we are working on Go 1.11.
MARK MANDEL: Very
good to hear that.
MELANIE WARRICK: So I know we've
just finished the announcements
at Next, but what
can developers expect
in the future for App Engine?
STEWART REICHLING: So
continued investment.
I think App Engine is
the thing that we're
going to continue investing
in pretty heavily.
Obviously, serverless
as a broader concept
with Cloud Functions
and App Engine
is what we think the
future is going to be.
And so we're looking
at more new runtimes,
as Steren just mentioned.
We're looking at graduating
more of these services the way
we have with Cloud
Tasks, Cloud Scheduler.
We're also looking
into new features
and how we can
continue to improve
App Engine, for example,
on the networking side,
we're always trying
to tune our scaler
to make it more performant.
And so you're going to see
basically more of the stuff
that we've been doing
over the last few months.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
And so what would you
want developers to do?
Like, should they just
read the docs, or like--
STEREN GIANNINI: Give it a try.
Try the new runtimes.
Give us feedback.
We want to improve App
Engine with your help.
Take our quick starts.
I think we even have
from the Cloud Console,
if you click App Engine, you
can have in console quickstart.
So without leaving
the browser, you
can deploy an App Engine app.
Or under the free tier--
so it will not cost you
anything to give it a try,
or even to run one instance
during every day for a month.
So really give it a try
and give us feedback.
We want to make it idiomatic
for you in your programming
language.
MARK MANDEL: And where should
they send that feedback?
STEWART REICHLING:
stewartr@google.com.
STEREN GIANNINI:
steren@google.com, steren
on Twitter.
MARK MANDEL: I assume there's
an App Engine Google Group,
as well.
STEWART REICHLING: Yeah.
We sit right next to each other.
We're a very close team.
So if you send us
feedback, we'll
make sure that reaches
the right people.
We want to hear from you.
STEREN GIANNINI: Lots of
questions, Stack Overflow.
I try to look at it
at least once a week.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's nice
and personable, too, frankly.
I mean, it's nice
that you want to be
available for that
type of feedback,
that you want to hear
from the community.
STEWART REICHLING: For sure.
It's the only way that
we know that we're
doing the right things.
MELANIE WARRICK: Agreed.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
So before we wrap up today,
have we missed anything,
or is there anything
you want to make sure
that people go and see?
I think you both
gave presentations.
Do you want to give their
names so that people
can find the recordings?
STEREN GIANNINI: At
the day two keynote,
we did a preview of an
exciting thing which
is serverless containers, so
allowing you to basically run
any programming language
or any custom binary
you might have within a
container in a serverless way,
so something that would scale
to zero with this same building
model as cloud functions.
So that's quite exciting.
MELANIE WARRICK: And
that is exciting.
STEREN GIANNINI: You
should check it out.
MELANIE WARRICK: We did have
somebody stop by the booth
earlier who said,
you need to talk
about serverless containers.
STEREN GIANNINI: Yeah, I'm
personally excited about that.
MARK MANDEL: Well,
once that's out,
you'll have to come
back on the podcast
and show us all about it.
STEWART REICHLING:
Love to come back.
STEREN GIANNINI: Yeah, we will.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: Well,
thank you so much,
both of you, for taking
the time today out
of your busy schedules
and hanging out
with us in the podcast booth.
STEWART REICHLING: Thank you.
STEREN GIANNINI: Thanks
Mark and Melanie.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Thank you again,
Steren and Stewart
for coming on the show
and talking to us about App
Engine and all the great things
that are going on
with App Engine.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
It was really good.
I mean, it's kind of crazy
that App Engine has been around
for so many years and they're
still doing stuff to it.
MELANIE WARRICK: I know.
I mean, Cloud started
with App Engine.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
It's a long life.
MELANIE WARRICK: It's long life,
but it keeps updating itself.
All right, well, Mark.
MARK MANDEL:
Question of the week?
MELANIE WARRICK: OK.
So we read in that
article, L1TF,
about how we as Google are
recommending that people make
sure they update their images.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, you
want to update your image.
What does that mean?
And I think that boils
down to sort of where
you're running your code.
I think we should probably just
talk about two particular ones.
One is, say, if you're
running your code on something
like a GCE instance, like
on a virtual machine,
or whether you're running
something inside a container.
I think those are the
two most important ones.
If you're running
it on top of GCE,
it's basically probably either
a Windows or Linux operating
system.
So if you're running,
say, like Debian,
which I'm most familiar
with, doing things like apt
get upgrade or get full
upgrade to do kernel updates,
as well, is important to do on
a regular basis, regardless.
And so when you
do that, make sure
if you're sitting behind a load
balancer, which you probably
are, then you can
then roll those
through behind your scenes
so that you don't necessarily
have to have any downtime
or anything like that,
which is super nice.
So make sure those
things are up to date.
If you're running
inside a container,
very much the same thing.
So you may want to
update your base image.
Make sure you're running
from the latest base
core operating system.
And if there are
particular packages that
need to be updated because
of certain security things,
make sure you get on
top of those, as well.
It's worth noting,
as well, we do
have the automated container
image security scanning,
as well.
So make sure you check
that on a regular basis.
That will actually
give you notifications
to let you know if there
are any particular security
issues inside your
images, as well, which
will link to CBEs,
which then you can see
exactly what's causing that.
And then you can update all
your stuff and that kind
of stuff, too.
MELANIE WARRICK: And then
two cents on this, too.
When we were reading
about this in the article,
one thing that
they'd stressed is
that you want to take this
into consideration, especially
if you're running your
own multitenant services.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK:
All right, Mark.
Where are you going to be?
MARK MANDEL: Where
am I going to be?
That is an excellent question.
So--
MELANIE WARRICK: Who are you?
MARK MANDEL: Who am I, and what
am I even doing with my life?
What has driven me to
come to this point?
MELANIE WARRICK: And now the
next hour or two of the podcast
is--
MARK MANDEL: Exactly.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah, go ahead.
MARK MANDEL: So I'll be
speaking at PAX Dev in Seattle,
looking forward to that and
hanging out at PAX West,
as well.
It's going to be awesome.
I'm also speaking at
the game development
section of Tokyo Next and be
hanging out there, as well.
So I'll be in Tokyo
for that, which
I'm really excited about
because I've never been before.
And then finally, I'm
heading to a Strange
Loop, although a little
late, because meetings.
And I'm really sad about that.
I love that conference.
MELANIE WARRICK: I know.
MARK MANDEL: I know.
But it'll be fine.
I'll be hanging out with you,
Melanie, and strangely enough,
a bunch of other Googlers,
as well, some of which
I'm also very excited about.
MELANIE WARRICK: Me too.
I know Jen and Holden,
who are our colleagues,
will be there and speaking--
MARK MANDEL: And speaking.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
I will be going to go to
Deep Learning Indaba in Cape
Town, South Africa.
And I'm going to be doing
some interviews there
for the podcast while
you are at Next.
And then after that,
of course, we're
going to both be at Strange
Loop, as Mark mentioned.
And I'm really looking
forward to this
because we will be hopefully
interviewing a friend of ours
that I've been trying--
MARK MANDEL: Oh, that'll be fun.
MELANIE WARRICK: --to get
onto the podcast for a while.
So looking forward to that.
She's the reason why Mark
and I even know each other.
Anyways, all right.
MARK MANDEL: Yes, it's
entirely her fault.
MELANIE WARRICK:
It is her fault.
And it was at Strange Loop.
So anyways, all right.
Well, Mark, I think that's
it for us for this week.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
Thank you for joining me for
yet another week on the podcast.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: And we'll
see you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]